peu
[Musique]
voulu voir vierzon et on a vu bien
heureusement
voulu voir vesoul a voulu voir ont
fleuri en l'avion flotter bout du banc
mambo et on a vu encore j'ai voulu voir
en vrai
c'est plus par ta soeur et on a vu que
ma mère
[Musique]
tous
plus aimé y en a qui quévert taf lévézou
on a quitté besoin
[Musique]
ta plume et on flingue ou de quitter mon
front
la plaie mais hambourg on a quitté rambo
t'as voulu voir en rêve on a aimé ta
mère on a quitté la salle
mais je te le dis je n'irai pas plus
loin
mais je te préviens
voyager finir à grave
tous les fronts la valse musette de
l'accordéon d'avoir ta ring on a vu
paris t'as voulu voir de temps et on a
mis du temps
j'ai voulu bartas heures j'ai vu le mont
valérien t'as voulu voir hortense et la
paix dans le comptage évolué voire dix
ans et on a vu pic à la gare
saint-lazare j'ai vu les pleurs du marin
larraza
leurs familles à quitter paris
d'après midi quand on a quitté du temps
[Musique]
on a évidemment rien de ce que l'os est
de retour
quant à elle en riant
mais gare à la gueule tapée
à
au hasard
mais j'adore
joe jeudi
mais
je n'ai pas
j'ai mal
le voyage est finie
[Musique]
folan
mais l'accord
la peine
[Musique]
les mamans fleurs il
nous avons nommé mon agent
marion
[Musique]
mais hambourg
la femme
mais j'adore
mais pas plus loin
m
un chauffeur fils me voient
ah j'ai fini
plan de laval et de la couronne
gemalto
[Musique]